guys when it comes to high level esports
play
strats win games i mean going over
hours of tape perfecting the current
meta running your plays again and again
in practice it's all a recipe for
competitive success
but sometimes you gotta throw all that
[ __ ] out the window
and do something truly crazy because
after all before a play is considered
innovative it's usually considered
insane
that's why we thought we'd bring you the
top 10 most insane esports strats
that actually worked
starting us off at the number 10 spot is
a cavera pick from rainbow six siege's
greatest team you thought this was a
show match this is for all the marbles
now kavera is let's say far from the
best operator in the game
sure she's annoying in your ranked games
but in pro league
well she's not what we'd call a team
player
but at the six major paris grand finals
g2 esports whipped out the cav
and showed us that even the gimmickiest
of operators
can shine on the big stage planting in
the back in the meantime us goes in for
the spray and mvk will go down
that's goga being lost by young holding
the angle extra gas scanners shot in the
back is
ionos again the second kill one more up
top he finds him
panko gets the kill on neck rock and
derek james
there you go all are spotted by pc and
claymore kill on fabian we've seen it
all
and it's literally round at number two
in the grand final young inn
defusers spotted and will get taken down
g2
what a beautiful retake
coming in at the number nine spot is an
insane pick that redefined
league of legends that's the pushing
lanes they actually
have done an insta-locked misfortune
something really weird i don't care
about my last point
this is an insta-locked misfortune
support mf
during the semi-finals of worlds 2016
skt
had the rox tigers firmly on the ropes
skt had taken the lead and
rox's hopes were looking a little dim
they needed something
crazy to beat faker but no one was
expecting just how crazy they were
willing to get
they can play safe and play aggressive
arrows land on the wolf and it's just
gonna be too much damage too
fast teleports be damned who cares a
two-on-two kill for the rock's bottom
lane
you beat zyra poke you out range it up
until the very moment
rox locked her in at support misfortune
was exclusively played
as an ad carry it looked like a troll
pick but prey and gorilla
proved that with the best bot lane in
the world anything
is possible also worth noting is sort of
put apart for the course yeah it's slope
getting caught at level four
here's the jump in a few more attacks
we'll do it and that's first
with the flash kick on the bank that was
beautiful
and they make it a double kill for prey
taking the number eight spot on our list
is league of legends ultimate flex pick
oh baby it's locked in that is pike and
yes ladies and gentlemen it is locked in
on the same roster as
tom kinch and no ladies and gentlemen it
was not with no time left so we're going
to see champion select rebate
frost that's a pike in 2019 g2
were on a roll and even facing down skt
and faker
g2 were still willing to bust out the
troll picks
looking to find even more now as wonder
closes in over the wall he goes looking
to maybe grab himself a bone skewer
nine nine nine nine that's some damage
on the enemy jungler make it two
a double kill for the top laner and
ladies and gentlemen the man is right
back in this game
target number three can they get him
chains are down
he's yoinked around and there comes your
ulti
now pike is not a top laner but
in the hands of the most creative team
on the planet he could beat
literally anything they wanted him to be
and g2 are on to the nexus turrets
those are down faker makes his stand but
he'll be buried beneath the x
g2 will repeat the success of the first
round robin
and take down skt
coming in at the number seven spot is
owie and dota 2's trolliest pick
he could be ganked a lot so oh
there we go welcome to the main event
for the hero that everyone loves to hate
and hates to love
when techies first came out players
weren't sure just how strong they might
be
but howie knew that there was a dark
potential
waiting to be unleashed when the heroes
in the game uh
only he's having fun that's how i feel
about it and did you have fun playing
of course he's super fun in theories
techies should suck
i mean all they do is put bombs around
the map and wait for enemies to step on
them
but at ti5 always show just how deadly
that skill can be
this time c deck is saying you're going
to play around us we're going to make
the moves
we're going to force you
all right yoda just poked out and the
undying died somebody's got to get out
there and fix it yeah
being they start going forward body
blocking close enough samantha's gonna
be able to get the change
do they have the damage already it looks
like it's cty
will be taken out first mod goes to
samael
before a play is considered an
innovative new strat
it's often considered insane the kind of
thing no one can pull off
well taking our number six spot is a
place so innovative
it still looks insane it's the roshan
bait
back in 2012 no tidehunter had a bit of
a reputation for going for early roshan
plays
and playing against evil geniuses at
dreamhack winter they figured they could
use that reputation
to their advantage the bait is lame
there's a small blood patch where
admiral [ __ ]
and it is it's actually a trap because
they came to check for it
now they're stunned it goes out they're
gonna bring it down
oh my james now on the penis
the swedes they pull something out of
the bag and feeders gonna go
down as well oh no tide hunter
what a stop what a strategy coming out
from eternal envy
by making it look like they were going
for an early roshan they tricked eg
into running headfirst into their trap
they weren't hunting roshan at all
they were hunting eg
coming in at number five is one of
melee's weirdest counterpicks
jigglypuff is the terror of pro melee
she slows games to a crawl with her
hit-and-run playstyle
combined with her ability to kill at
lower percent
for years people thought that fox was
the only character good enough to keep
up with her
but at pound five smash god armada
pulled out a counter pick
from the very bottom of the tier list
i'm still going young link versus
hungrybox all right first and foremost
i gotta say oh my goodness wow
beautiful
wow did you see the fake there took away
another option
really smart young link has never been
considered a good character
and yet somehow armada made it work
beating hungrybox see hungrybox played
him towards center stage
[Applause]
i must say armada has my stamp of
approval we're going young link
all right guys you knew this was coming
it had to be on this list
taking the number four spot is the
infamous olaf boost
most famous probably at this point for
appearing in 400 the score esports top
10 lists
the olaf boost comes from the
quarterfinals of dreamhack winter 2014
where fnatic were getting absolutely
thrashed by ldlc
but after the first half fnatic turned
the tides by pulling out a truly
wild play out of nowhere pretty standard
game although do they have a weird boost
going on currently yeah
fnatic busted out a secret spot on
overpass to boost
allowing olaf to snipe at ldlc without
fear of reprisal
all of meister is still waiting the
patience game coming i can spot them
coming out of the street door as well
he's here
he sees them down there straight
headshot they have no idea
smith's looking confused and dazed and
there's gonna be a follow-up
shut up you've gotta be kidding me take
the okay
shimmer as well oh it finally works and
now for that's it
this is the comeback moment for them
unfortunately the olaf boost was too
controversial to last
fnatic decided to forfeit the match
after they were forced to replay it and
valve patched it out of the game
but it lives on forever in our hearts
and on our top ten lists
coming into the number three spot on our
list is a place so crazy
it never actually existed it's hux
hallucinations from mlg dallas 2011.
oh well oh
man you know what starcraft is
not only a very intensive mental game
but it can be psychological
as well back in the glory days of
starcraft 2 huck and idra
were known for their fierce rivalry and
love for trash talk
and at mlg dallas their rivalry came to
its boiling point
idra was up one game and looking to
close at the second
when huck suddenly struck back with an
army of void rays
out of nowhere here's the thing though
the void rays weren't real they were
hallucinations
and oh my gosh void race now out on the
field and it looks like there's some
circles during the counter attack in the
main
the void rays all hallucinations doing
absolutely
no damage whatsoever there's the blink
up onto the high ground just trying to
distract idra
those hallucinated void rays almost
fully charged wheat
and idra left the game
oh now we when i first played brood war
someone said wouldn't it be funny if you
hallucinated a bunch of carriers and
your opponent just left
that is what we just saw here at mlg
not even huck expected this one to work
challenging faker is rarely a good idea
but edg
pulled it off in incredible fashion and
their masterful bait
is taking the runner-up spot on our list
at msi 2015
faker was looking absolutely unstoppable
so edg decided to serve him a nice slice
of humble pie
baker has never lost
with leblanc on the competitive stage
12 and 0. see every team at the
tournament was banning leblanc
faker's signature champion but edg were
just
insane enough to leave it up and even
taunted him
into picking it and once he locked her
in edg
drafted a comp designed to clap faker
and guess what they did elixir of
sorcery on him as well to get out a bit
of extra damage goro finds him with the
twisted advance as he pulls back the
distortion
and he can't get out alive marin is
forced to turn as soon as he nars out
unfortunate for skt this is another very
dangerous bear and edg needs it to win
here comes sk telecom banking not there
for the 50-50
baron going very low at 1500 it is going
to go over to cleveland
they take down faker immediately sk
telecom t1 are wiped the nexus turrets
are going down
lpl's edward gaming are the 2015
mid-season invitational champions
[Applause]
taking the top spot on our list is the
god of dota
carrying with the most unlikely hero in
the game
he's just kind of used to i'm pretty
sure just beating ta in this game
and as we see the first phase bands
what's the new change elder titan gets
panned out and guess what slips through
it's the io og
immediately snap it up anna appears once
a year at ti to show the world why he's
considered the god of dota
and in his hands even a support hero
like wisp can
carry games this is just fountain
bombing
gee you got it this is soul breaking
[Applause]
jj okay
wisp is at its best when your team is
working together
with you supporting them instead at ti9
anna had the rest of the team working to
enable him
and he pulled off truly dazzling plays
they're just look at this they're diving
in ti
as well oh my god i can't believe this
i can't believe what we're seeing in
this game for every single team
underestimated just how devastating
the carry wisp could be and ana ranch
circles around them all
helping og win their second straight ti
[Applause]
title
all right guys that about does it for
the top 10 insane esports chats
that actually worked and this is the
point in the video where i tell you to
go on over to twitch.tv
slash the score esports give us a follow
turn notifications on
because we are going live on the regular
with exclusive content to twitch
content you won't find anywhere else so
do it
okay ric flair you know pro wrestler
gross old guy who goes woo let's do some
ric flair impressions first of all whoa
second of all you belong to the nature
boy
tonight in biloxi the consortium
was me we're partners no one's gonna get
these
rick flair ladies and gentlemen woo